hey there
welcome to cloud on air live webinars
from google cloud
we're hosting webinars every tuesdays
this march
i'm saumia kannan i'm a technical
curriculum developer
in the google cloud platform training
team and this is my co-host
i'm elaine biddle and i'm also a
technical curriculum developer for gcp
brian rice our technical curriculum lead
has graciously volunteered to be our q a
moderator
we want to answer as many questions as
we can so leave your questions on the
webinar platform
we'll answer a lot of them live and if
we run out of time we'll make sure to
type out the responses to the ones that
we
don't get a chance to cover thank you
brian
today's webinar is all about learning
how
stackdriver features enabled webinar is
all about
learning how stackdriver features enable
you to debug
monitor trace and enable logging in your
applications
that are running on google kubernetes
engine
this webinar will be relevant for cloud
professionals building
cloud native applications on google
cloud platform
if you enjoy today's webinar definitely
check out
the developing applications with google
cloud platform
specialization on coursera at the end of
the webinar you'll receive
a voucher to get started with the
courses in the specialization
if you want to learn more about the
training that we have to offer
check out cloud.google.com training
all right let's see what we have in
store for you today
uh we'll be talking about cloud native
applications and microservices
we'll look at a couple of customer case
studies
and melane here has lined up a couple of
neat demos for us about
microservices and stackdriver we'll wrap
up with some q a
microservices seem to be the rage in
software engineering today
and rightly so
traditionally monolithic applications
were the norm and with monolithic
applications the problem is that the
code base becomes
bloated over time it can be difficult to
determine where code needs to be changed
and packages can have tangled
dependencies
the entire application needs to be
deployed and tested
even if a change is made to a small part
of the application
this increases the effort and the risk
that you have to take when you're making
feature changes and bug fixes
microservices on the other hand enable
you to structure your application
components
to match business boundaries the code
base for each service is
modular each service can be updated
and deployed independently without
requiring your customers
to change at the same time each service
can be scaled independently depending on
load
for each microservice teams can use
different programming languages and
toolkits that work
best for the problem that they are
trying to solve
well-designed microservices are loosely
coupled at runtime
tightly coupled components can make an
application
less resilient to failures spikes in
traffic
and changes to services an intermediate
component such as
a message queue can be used to implement
loose coupling
perform asynchronous processing and
buffer messages in case of
spikes in traffic you can use a cloud
pub sub topic as a message queue
publishers can publish messages to the
topic
and subscribers can subscribe to
messages from the topic
in the example that you see here the
order service can
continue to publish messages to the
message queue
even if the inventory service is down
and later when the inventory service
comes back online
it can retrieve all orders from the
message queue
including the ones that came in when the
service was down
that's pretty cool milan why don't you
tell us about
the microservices demo that you've lined
up for us
sure thanks omiya so
the microservices demo is a crop
cross-platform application
that demonstrates microservice best
practices some of them described by
sonya
the architecture of the demo services
microservices application
was intentionally designed to provide as
many
microservices as possible it was also
written in multiple languages
java.net core go and node.js
as she mentioned so that different parts
of the team
can really write the code and the
microservice based on the problem
they're trying to solve
and it also exercises a number of
different technologies
as you see in the architecture diagram
the microservices are roughly defined by
the functions of an e-commerce site
the demo i'm going to show you uses a
fake web store application
called the sock shop and it runs on
google kubernetes engine
before exploring what it takes to debug
and monitor the application
we're going to explore the application
in order to do that i'm going to switch
over to the console
and in the console
just get my mouse over here i'm going to
go to kubernetes engine
you can see here when we go to
kubernetes engine that my sock shop
cluster has been deployed
when i navigate to discovery and load
balancing
we're going to see about 14 separate
microservices that have been deployed as
part of this cluster
that's pretty neat so over a dozen
microservices have to play well together
in order for this demo to work well
absolutely and again like we showed you
in the diagram
they're all written in different
languages so you could have you know
one team working on one piece and
another with the other and they all
seamlessly work together
to get to the webpage front end i'm
going to click here on this endpoint
and here we have our sock shop so i'm
going to generate
some order points and some errors that i
know exist
so that we can really figure out what's
going on with this application so i'm
going to go in here and i am going to
add these crossed socks i'm going to
look in my cart
and so here we see there's one pair of
cross socks
i am going so i let's say i had a
customer report
that when they added something to the
cart and then
updated the quantity to zero
and then clicked update basket that it
updated the quantity
but it's still kept it in the cart so
obviously that's an error we've
generated an error yep
so i'll remove that and we'll look into
that later
and now i'm just going to add some more
data points i am going to add to the
cart
i'm going to go back into my cart i'm
going to log
in so that i can complete an order
it's funny there's a market for holy
socks you never know
so if i go back in here you never know
so if i go back in here i'm going to
click proceed to checkout
and i've now created one order so
i'm going to go back into here and i'm
going to add a couple more socks so we
have a couple more data points
as that refreshes i'll go in here
proceed to checkout
and i'm going to add one more pair of
socks i actually had a customer report
that when they add the colorful to the
cart that it takes longer than the
others
as you can see there seemed to be some
latency around that so that's something
that maybe we should look into later
so i'll go ahead and click back into the
cart proceed to checkout
and now we say we have three separate
orders that we can look into
in stackdriver so with that i will hand
it back to somya
there we go
uh so you know you're probably sold on
the benefits of microservices
uh you you've been listening to the buzz
in the industry today microservices have
many advantages
but they bring a new set of challenges
related to
complexity communication between
services
latency and debugging debugging logging
and monitoring a distributed application
can seem pretty daunting
stackdriver helps provide greater
visibility
and increase application reliability you
can monitor gcp and multi-cloud
environments
identify trends and prevent issues
reduce monitoring overhead and fix
problems faster
stackdriver improves signal to noise
ratio
remember you want to wake up your
on-call support folks
for real emergencies only
you really don't want to be in a
situation where you find out from your
customers on social media
that your application is down it's
important to monitor the status of your
application and services
to ensure that they're always available
and performing optimally
the monitoring data can be used to
automatically alert operations teams as
soon as the system begins to fail
operations teams can then diagnose and
address the issue promptly
ideally before your customers even
realize that the allegation is down
implement a health check endpoint for
each service
the point handler should check the
health of
all dependencies and infrastructure
components
required for the service to function
properly for example
the endpoint handler that you see here
can check the performance and
availability of storage
database and network connections
required by the service
the endpoint handler should return an
http response code
of 200 for successful health checks and
if the health check fails
the endpoint handler can return a
response code of
503 or a more specific response code
depending on the error
a health monitoring agent such as a load
balancer or stack driver monitoring
can periodically send requests to a
health check endpoint
load balancers use health checks to
determine if an application
instance is healthy and is capable of
receiving traffic
if the health check fails beyond the
threshold that you've defined
stackdriver monitoring can send you an
alert automatically
treat your logs as event streams that's
another best practice here
logs constitute a continuous stream of
events that keep occurring as long as
your application is running
don't manage log files in your
application that can get really clunky
really fast
instead write to an event stream such as
standard out
and let the underlying infrastructure
collate all events for later analysis
and storage
with this approach you can set up logs
based metrics
and trace requests across services in
your application
with google stackdriver you can debug
your application
set up error reporting set up logging
and logs based metrics
trace requests across services and
monitor applications running in a
multi-cloud environment
all right here's a customer case study a
builder trend
develops cloud-based software and mobile
apps for
construction professionals they have
tools for managing pre-sales
projects customers and financials
frustrated by frequently slow
performance builder trend
switch from a shared cloud
infrastructure to google cloud platform
the company now delivers more reliable
performance to customers
stackdriver monitoring is a key
component of their application
along with google bigquery and google
compute engine
great to hear of a customer who went all
in and how it's helping them
uber site reliability engineer ryan
shatford explained how they use
stackdriver for monitoring
dashboards and policy-based alert
management
uber quickly created dashboards to
visualize monitoring data
for compute instances and for vpn
statistics
millain i'd love to see your demo about
stackdriver monitoring logging and
trace absolutely
so like somia mentioned stackdriver
trace is a key tool that helps you
understand
latency in your applications by showing
you how long actual customer requests
are taking
through every step of the journey
through a distributed system
there's a traffic generator included in
the project that we actually give you a
link to on github
and it's sending traffic to our
application which is sufficient for
trace to provide
more information about the latency so
let me go ahead and switch
back to the console there we go
let me go back to the console and i am
now going to navigate
to stackdriver trace
hey look at that this application
uh has a health check endpoint
implemented and you can see
on the screen here that stackdriver is
sending
um doing a health check every couple
minutes or so
and receiving data back pretty neat
pretty cool
so i'm going to switch to the trace list
and so here in the trace list we have
some information about the spans
so each span represents one of the steps
that was completed during the processing
of a request so i'm going to filter it
because there's a lot of information
and i'm just going to look at the orders
and if you recall we made a couple of
orders if we click here on the span
we're going to get more information
about what was happening in each step if
we scroll down and look at the timeline
we get more
information about the steps of the
requests that are happening both in
parallel and sequentially
so that's pretty nice right so you can
visualize
which of your calls are happening uh in
a serial manner and which are happening
in parallel and even identify areas of
optimization so if you see that there's
a bunch of calls happening seriously
serially which you could instead do in
parallel
then that would reduce the amount of
time that it takes for you to
uh request um so really great uh
insight into what's happening under the
hood with your application
yeah it really gives you a good overall
picture from a lot of data points of
what's happening in a timeline based
view in your application so now that
we've looked a little bit into the trace
i'm going to go
over to stackdriver error reporting and
look into that error that we tried to
replicate that let's say a customer told
us they encountered
so when we navigate to error reporting
first thing we see
is an error and i will for transparency
i did generate the error a couple times
before we started this demo but we did
generate it once here
so when we click into the error details
it's going to show you
how many times did this happen so
obviously if you were replicating
something a customer saw you could say
okay well i did it once
the customer saw it 15 times we need to
fix this it tells you the first time it
was seen
and then the last time it was seen super
helpful so this is the one i generated
just now
we have a couple more details up here if
you click on the overflow menu
it gives you the option to turn on
notifications for the error group
that's really useful so that you can
always monitor what's going on and it's
one click away
you also have a resolution status
with the resolution status you can go in
here and for this error group you can
say i've acknowledged it our team's
working on it
you can say it's resolved if you resolve
an error group and then you
it crops up again you didn't really fix
it then you'll automatically be notified
that the error group you
previously resolved has now been
reopened
so now that we have that we have a
couple more details if you
look down here in the errors and you
want to see exactly what was happening
at the time of the error i can click
here on view logs
and it's going to navigate me to
stackdriver logging
and it's going to filter it down to the
time when that error happened
a lot of things are happening though so
this isn't super easy to parse through
so i'm going to filter to just the
errors
because it's showing me all of the logs
of everything that happened for all of
the microservices and as we saw
there's a handful two handfuls
so here is our error if i expand it
and then i look at the labels it gives
me lots of information about the air
and it's actually telling me that the
error happened right here in this front
end pond
pod if i click here and then look at
show matching entries
it's then going to go to the advanced
filter for logging
where it's showing me all of the errors
that happened for that specific pod
now i also want to see what happened
before
and after the error for this pod and
since this
detailed um filter has already been
filled out for me
i'm going to remove the severity of
error
resubmit the filter and now i can see
here's my error here is what happened
exactly before the error
and then what happened after it that's
pretty cool so
you don't have to wait through log files
instead
you're able to quickly zone in on the
problem area
and try to understand what's going on
with your application
absolutely it's very powerful to do it
this way
so now that we have some context around
what's wrong
let's go back to that error
and so we're going to dive into the
problem a little bit more by looking at
snapshots a snapshot
captures the local variables and call
stack at a specific line location in
your source code
so when we look at the error details
you'll see that it actually tells you
the exact line of code where this broke
right here
it's in the index.js file at line 165.
so if i click here it is going to
redirect me to stackdriver debug
wait for that to load